عربات مدرعة في شوارع
موسكو حيث تقول وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية هذه الساعة إنه تم
تشديد الإجراءات الأمنية
في موسكو وتقول وسائل الإعلام الحكومية أيضًا إن
بوتين على علم بالوضع الذي يتكشف
حول يفغيني باغوسيان، قائد
جيش فاغنر الخاص، فإن الوضع
خطير للغاية الليلة تلك الدولة
اقتحم التلفزيون البرامج المجدولة
لإيصال هذه الرسالة إلى
الشعب الروسي من وزارة الدفاع الروسية،
وانتشرت جميع الرسائل ولقطات الفيديو على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي نيابة عن
الباغوسي الأفغاني الذي يُزعم أن وزارة
الدفاع في الاتحاد الروسي
نفذت ضربات  إن ما حدث في
المعسكرات الخلفية لـ Wagner PMC ليس صحيحًا وهو عبارة عن
برمجة استفزازية إعلامية لـ
10 أشخاص لعدم الاستماع إلى البريغوسيان
أثناء وجود المركبات المدرعة في
شوارع موسكو، وتأتي هذه التطورات
بعد أن أعلن باغوسيان اليوم
الحرب على الجيش الروسي
لأنه فعل ذلك  اتهمهم
بتعمد ضرب مقاتليه
وقتل عدد كبير منهم
ثم توعد بمعاقبة من
فعل ذلك يا إلهي لقد
رأوا أننا لم ننكسر
وشنوا ضربات على معسكراتنا
عدد كبير من مقاتلينا  لقد
قُتل
رفاقنا وسلاحنا،
وسنتخذ قرارًا بشأن كيفية
الرد على هذه الفظائع،
والخطوة التالية هي أن مجموعة فاغنر المرتزقة
أصدرت مقطع فيديو يظهر على ما يبدو أن
زعيمها لديك غينيا
بريجوسيان في مدينة روستوف الروسية
على نهر الدون، قادمًا كما يلي:
تتهمه الحكومة الروسية بالدعوة
إلى تمرد مسلح. وقال باغوسيان في وقت سابق إن
قواته دخلت
منطقة روستوف من أوكرانيا وأن
الجيش الروسي ينضم إلى مقاتليه
بينما تقدم القافلة مقاطع فيديو من
المنطقة تظهر مركبات عسكرية
وأفرادًا في الشوارع.  لكن من
غير الواضح من الذي أمرهم
بالانتزاع المبكر قال إن قواته تقوم
بما أسماه مسيرة العدالة
ضد وزارة الدفاع التي
يزعم أنها قتلت العديد من مرتزقته في
ضربة
رأوا أننا لم ننكسر
وشنوا ضربات على موقعنا  لقد
قُتل عدد كبير من مقاتلينا في المعسكرات
ورفاقنا في السلاح، حسنًا،
سنتخذ قرارًا بشأن كيفية
الرد على هذه الفظائع، والخطوة
التالية هي خطوتنا
الآن، يهدف هذا الفيديو إلى إظهار الموقع
الذي يُزعم أن الغارة حدثت فيه، لكن
CNN لا يمكنها التحقق من صحته  في
الوقت الحالي،
كان منذ فترة طويلة قائدًا مرتزقًا معروفًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم، والآن أصبح
تقدم يوجين رجلًا مطلوبًا في روسيا، كما
أنه في كثير من الأحيان مجموعة من المقاتلين الذين لا يرحمون
يتم تحريضهم الآن ضد
القيادة العسكرية الروسية وأصبح بريجوسيان
فجأة العدو العام لموسكو رقم
واحد فلاديمير.  بوتين يدعو
مجموعة الإيقاع إلى إلقاء أسلحتهم
كل أولئك الذين اختاروا عمدا
طريق الخيانة والذين أعدوا
تمردًا مسلحًا واختاروا طريق الابتزاز
والأساليب الإرهابية سيواجهون
عقابًا لا مفر منه وسيحاسبون
أمام القانون وشعبنا.
أصبح الآن عدوًا
لفلاديمير بوتين، لكن
علاقته التي استمرت لعقود من الزمن مع
الرئيس الروسي هي التي سمحت لبريغوجان
بتأسيس ميليشيا خاصة به، حيث
عملت مجموعة فاغنر كجيش خاص يقوم
بمهام مثيرة للجدل غالبًا لا يستطيع حتى
الجيش الروسي القيام بها.
استخدم سجين سابق ورجل قوي من سانت بطرسبرغ
فاغنر للعمل في جميع أنحاء العالم.
وقد تعقبت سي إن إن مرتزقة فاغنر إلى
جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى والسودان وليبيا
وموزمبيق وأوكرانيا وسوريا على طول
الطريق الذي أثرى
بريغوسيان نفسه، واتهمت جماعات حقوق الإنسان فاغنر بأعمال
مروعة.  يُزعم أن أعمال عنف مثل هذه التي
قام بها مقاتلو فاغنر حطموا أقدام
وأيدي سجين سوري بمطرقة
ثقيلة في عام 2017. وبحسب ما
ورد توفي الرجل بعد محنته، فإن
الصور مزعجة بشكل لا يصدق مثل
العديد من الصور الأخرى المنسوبة إلى مجموعته
لسنوات عديدة، ونفى بريغوسي
وجود وجود  كان من الأفضل أن يتم عمل فاغنر
سرًا، وهو سيد الأسطورة مما جعله
بريجوسيًا، وكان فاغنر هو الذي أنشأ
مزرعة القزم الروسية سيئة السمعة التي استخدمت
لنشر معلومات مضللة حول
الانتخابات الرئاسية الأمريكية لعام 2016،
ولكن عندما نزل مقاتلوه إلى
ساحة المعركة في شرق أوكرانيا وبدأوا في
الفوز بالمعارك.  يبدو أن سكان بريجوسي
يريدون تسليط الضوء على
عملية الباركود التي بدأت في 8 أكتوبر
2022 من أجل إعطاء
فرصة للجيش الروسي المنهك لاستعادة
قواتنا التي اقتحمت هذه المدينة لمدة 224 يومًا ولم
يكن هناك سوى قوات فاغنر الخاصة هنا، وهي
قوات سيئة التدريب على ما يسمى
باللحوم.  طاحونة الحرب في شرق أوكرانيا التي
عانت من عدد مذهل من
الضحايا في محاولة للتغلب على
احتياطات الدفاعات، حطمت انتصاراته
في مواجهة وزارة الدفاع الروسية المتعثرة التي
تنفيس عن غضبها من العشوائية
والتخطيط السيئ للغزو الروسي غير القانوني
وتوبيخ كبار الضباط الروس الذين يسخرون
وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويجو
أوس،
تعتقد أنك أسياد هذه
الحياة، تعتقد أنك
تستطيع التخلص من حياتهم، تعتقد
أن لديك مستودعات
مليئة بالذخيرة التي لديك
الآن، ربما يكون سلاح الكرملين السري
أكبر تهديد لبليكين سي إن إن
برلين
جيدًا  قيل لي إن البيت الأبيض
يراقب بنشاط هذا
الوضع المتكشف داخل روسيا، وهو
وضع حساس للغاية. وقيل لي إن
الرئيس بايدن قد تم إطلاعه بالفعل
على هذا الوضع داخل روسيا ولدي
أيضًا هذا البيان من
المتحدث باسم مجلس الأمن القومي.  آدم
هودج الذي يقول اقتباسا نحن نراقب
الوضع وسنقوم بالتشاور
مع الحلفاء والشركاء بشأن هذه
التطورات الآن
أخبرني مسؤولان آخران في الإدارة أن
مسؤولي البيت الأبيض سيستمرون في
مراقبة ما يحدث أه
داخل روسيا عن كثب وهم يتوخون
الحذر كما  من يوم الجمعة، لا ينبغي لنا أن نعلق
كثيرًا على الوضع حتى
يصبح أكثر وضوحًا ما
يحدث بالضبط بين زعيم المرتزقة الروسي
يفغيني براغوسيان ووزارة
الدفاع الروسية، ولكن مهما كان
الوضع، فمن الواضح أن هناك
آثارًا هائلة على هذه التوترات
داخل روسيا، فقد قامت الولايات المتحدة  لقد قمنا منذ فترة طويلة
بمراقبة تلك التوترات بين
مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر ووزارة
الدفاع الروسية، وبالطبع تم
فرض عقوبات على كلا الجانبين من قبل
الولايات المتحدة لدورهما في
الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا، ونحن نعلم أن
مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر لعبت دوراً
متزايداً  دورًا رئيسيًا في
المجهود الحربي العسكري الروسي داخل أوكرانيا، لذلك من
المؤكد أنه يوم الجمعة كان هذا
موقفًا متوترًا للغاية ومتكشفًا، حيث
سيواصل البيت الأبيض
مراقبة جيريمي دايموند سي إن إن
البيت الأبيض